a major accomplishment for a local  student how this high school junior  managed to get a perfect score  on both the s.a.t and the a.c.t  studying he probably studied a bit yeah  good day las vegas starts right now  live this is good day las vegas the  valley's news leader  it's amazing what that will do it  reminds me it reminds me of when i would  go to i remember taking the test for the  acds and the seds at chaparral  and being petrified before i walked in  there and afraid i was going to upset  the proctor and all of that it was  nerve-wracking why would you upset them  i don't know because i'm me  okay how did your test go not well  i mean apparently it went well enough  all right good morning everybody 6 30  the time  uh nate you always joke around with us  about we won't be tested on this  right well you know what i got on the  s.a.t test what  drool thank you